so I'm pretty much tapped out for
material so I'll just tell you something
kind of cute that I threw together in
some spare time so I was on Hacker News
one day and I saw this library that
somebody wrote called did you mean for
Ruby and so when you it overloaded
method missing so that when you type the
name of an attribute or a method that
didn't exist it would say or did you
mean this other method so I thought
could we do this for Python it turns out
there's a lot of small ways you know for
Python you can use sis not accept hook
so that you can trap and attribute error
all the way the top level and give a did
you mean message or you could overwrite
the built-in get a derp but I thought is
there a more interesting way we can do
this and so I came up with this so me
pip install d UTC did you mean this will
work on linux and mac 64 bits but it
won't work on we should do it on this
one I've got a virtual infant here
somewhere so did you mean it'll work on
anything about Windows you can see it
does something a little bit wild in the
background and i'll show you how it
works so let's use our Python here so
you have some class that you've written
what some method and you create an
instance of the class and you try to
access the method you misspelled it it
gives you this error you import did you
mean you try it again and it says oh
maybe you meant for and you think oh I
wonder how I did it so let me try to
maybe he used this not accept talk but
if you insist on except hook then if you
did this and you captured the exception
yourself the exception message shouldn't
have my messages so I didn't use
systolic septic you might say oh maybe
he did something to override the get at
ER because I saw work with get at her
our let me import
so let's just do this I'll see it there
so what I'll do is I'll start I'll get a
reference to get at her just in case he
tries to patch that and then I'll get a
derp the message is there and if i use
my reference that I captured before the
message is still there so as a module
this doesn't do anything interesting
whatsoever in fact I think it's actually
fairly boring module but I think it's
really interesting is how I got this to
work so if you're trying figure how you
got it to work we can go into we can go
into they'll did we mean and I'll
actually show you the source code for it
so I'll go into my know and you can see
there was some C code in the background
so let's take a look at the sea module
that I create a little bit of sea coding
here and if you look through this you
can see something weird i hooked by
object get a tour if you look at the
very bottom there's this function here
called hook function and if you look at
hook function you can see what
identified was there are different ways
of hooking into a sea school right we
have this LD preload so if you have a
dot if you have a shared object and you
want to override the lookup and the
linker for what it resolves to when you
call a function in some shared object
module what will happen is you'll just
you can you can preempt that so you can
do things like import your own or
implement your own custom malloc or free
or some debugging purpose but
unfortunately within a Python executable
you can't do that because they're not
shared object it's just a direct
opposite so what you have to do is
something like this what I wrote was a
very simple little piece of code that
finds the function of memory smashes the
top part of the function with little
jump a trampoline trampolines to my own
function and implements that and so the
way that I got this to work was I found
pi object get a dar the most fundamental
entry point into the whole getattr cycle
and I replace it with my own one now
unfortunately pile up to get out our
calls itself because it needs to call
the door command in case it needs to I
need to call the door commander in order
to figure out by levenshtein distance
the the method that you probably wanted
and that will call pi optic editor
itself so I ended up having to cut and
paste quite a bit
of this whole chain so that I wouldn't
end up in infinite recursion and the
other interesting thing is you might say
this is probably not what you should do
and you probably shouldn't do this
because you're violating this kind of no
execute principle we have code we
shouldn't be able to multi modify this
code but in the process of looking at
this I noticed something very
interesting in Linux there is you have
this self your of this proc self file
system that it exports a couple of
properties on the currently running
process and one of the things that
exports is maps and maps draw your
memory maps and what you can see is that
for for my memory maps for something
like a Python process some of them are
read write and some of them are
read-only there's also something
exported through the proc file system
called mem and you can seem Em is read
right what that means is actually
irrespective of the read write execute
bits that are on that are on some [ __ ]
part of memory you can actually write
through proc self mem to any part of
memory that you want and so you can
implement this from a pure python
process and smash the stack however you
want without having to write any C code
without having to do anything like I did
in mind where I have to actually call
unprotect I think it's month end or so
that's did you mean thank you
so what I did is I really don't use that
much Python I'm much more of an hour
person so I wanted to sign up for
lightning talk to put some stakes in the
ground and actually start coding in
Python since I came to the conference I
got the t-shirt this seems like the next
logical step once this loads I can
actually get started with the
presentation okay so the first thing is
kind of what is correspondence analysis
this is not a correspondence analysis
but this is going to help explain why
we're doing it um business people really
like these four box charts they really
do it so there's only a few ways to do
them the most common ways just to start
throwing you know darts at a board of
that vaguely work based on whatever your
for box chart in this case happens to be
there is a data-driven way to to
approach this though and that is a
correspondence analysis the court at the
top is from Wikipedia in a similar
manner to a principal component analysis
it provides a means for displaying and
summarizing data in a two-dimensional
graphical form how that works kind of
behind the scenes is essentially just
creating a difference matrix and then
it's slowly taking those distances
between everything and finding out how
it can squeeze them into a single box in
this case what I decided to do is I
decided to run through this entire
process which looks a lot prettier when
I show it with little icons so we're
analyzing social media here social media
is notoriously dirty but using this
process we can take that dirtiness
somehow quantify it and then create
these four box charts with them in this
case some dude is tweeting about taco
bell McDonald's KFC chick-fil-a or
whatever and then they are deciding to
you know give us that information which
we are more than willing to accept take
and parson Python I still haven't
necessarily broken out of our yet so I
did the final analysis and our but I did
find a
code repository that has a
correspondence analysis implementation
in Python if I ever want to refactor
this code and perform an all in Python
without you know transferring it to a
file reading that file in our the way
that works is pretty simple I'm reading
data from Twitter like anybody else
would probably do in this situation then
I'm parsing these tweets just reading
them out cashing them to strings and
then I'm just using that list with every
single string that's available in those
tweets to perform a lot of different
transformations first I'm setting them
to a set so I can get the unique
different words that were used in those
tweets and i'm only using words that
were used multiple times i'm using
somewhere between three and six there
are nine actual restaurants that i'm
looking at in this data set and I picked
between three and six randomly because
we don't want it to be too sparse
because then it's just making more data
that we don't need and we don't want it
to be too large because most of this
analysis is based on the fact that there
need to be distances between the
different restaurants after doing that I
start to analyze my data shrink it down
and I also create a word count again
that's stored as a dick dictionary
object that I will then use to create a
matrix of the different words that I'm
using in this corpus of corporate corpus
of the restaurant analysis finally I'm
kind of transposing that matrix to make
it easier to then read into our later
once again that's kind of the gap in
this analysis is that I don't know how
to implement this algorithm and Python
just yet and I start reading it into our
another reason why it was implemented in
our is because it was incredibly simple
and I only did this in four hours so the
single line to run a correspondence
analysis which is just CA with
parentheses was really helpful as you
can see that's a mess it's really hard
to see what's going on under the blobs
of bread to explain what's going on here
if it's blue that means that's a
restaurant if it's red that's a word
that was identified using kind of what i
like to call the word hot list which is
me looking through my corpus of words
I'd
find things that look very foodie such
as fries dinner lunch breakfast burgers
hungry I was then able to create a new
list that's much more parts ammonium and
it is allowing us to kind of see what's
going on with the different restaurants
in this analysis some interesting things
that we can find out here is that a lot
of people think chipotle is an
acceptable dates so that is you know
it's very popular on twitter for dating
also breakfast at both qdoba and
mcdonalds is a thing so I used to work
at qdoba so that's very near and dear to
my heart so I know how good the
breakfast is and I can recommend it also
grows like Burger King and kotoba not so
much as hungry and craving people like
Taco Bell obviously this analysis needs
a little bit more work so I think over
the next few months I'm going to try to
tune this make it into a real
presentation and talk that can be
extended so the next steps here would be
to obviously pull in more data using the
free API I was only limited to 100
tweets getting more would be much better
from there I could then use tf-idf to
identify which words only applied to
food rather than using you know me
looking at my giant corpus of words and
seeing what looks like it fit with the
food topic finally I could use lda to
then shrink the list of topics in these
tweets to group them together and
provide a better distance Minh matrix
finally I would then recreate the exact
same analysis both using correspondence
analysis and multi-dimensional scaling
which is then going to shrink it to two
dimensions but also provide some
interesting features around continuous
vectors finally if we add demographic
information to it in the same way that
we have these red items here which
usually indicate a word you can also
overlay the demographics of the
different people tweeting and that's it
thank you
so like some of the other talks this one
is also sort of a cute little trick to
work around lots of this one particular
issue that all of us have faced before
operating on a list concurrently so we
had an object in our datastore it's no
sequel and it contained a list of items
that we didn't really care about where
their order was where they were and
later requirements change required us to
be able to operate on it and do so
concurrently so we could insert
add/remove basically was designed for
real-time collaboration so I want to be
able to insert between one and two what
do I have to do I have to shift everyone
over so that kind of stinks so in
addition we have some new constraints
one of them was we had multiple users
operating currently we had now deal with
this in real time to handle real-time
updates which we were doing which was
backing her firebase interaction we
couldn't use locking or transactions
because they were too slow and our CEO
said of course we need it yesterday how
many of us have dealt with that so yeah
welcome to fail so we learn by failing
so our standard solution was locked the
object iterate over the list iterate
lock those and then do our rights and it
was slow and one of the options is just
deal with it that wasn't a good option
the second one was taking advantage of
the parent-child relationship of objects
in in DB which soared no sequel
datastore to simulate a list this means
that basically you can do what's called
an ancestor query to get the list of
results back in an order by some number
which we could call the index or the
rank and that was really slow still not
as bad as the first one but we still had
to lock on every single item after the
insertion point so it didn't really get
rid of that first problem so weirdly
enough I did not like either of these
solutions i went home and the solution
came to me in the form of a question
from my mathematically inclined daughter
she said to me later that night how many
numbers exist between one and two
and all of a sudden we had an answer we
don't have to shift them anymore whoever
said that list ranks have to be integers
so if we combine it ancestor
relationship to get rid of the list so
no locks there and we don't have to
shift everything what do we get we get
exactly what we want we can now insert
into the list by reading the to the
indexes of the two neighbors and we can
do this any number of times and maintain
the original semantics so insert
something between two and three insert
something else between two and three who
cares as long as they're both between
two and three right you you did you used
to fulfill up the contract so this can
be done over and over and over again and
it doesn't matter and one of the things
that makes this work is the precision of
floating point numbers in Python which
are much higher than they are in
languages like C and C++ and Java and so
on which buys us time to be able to
change them back to the integers when
the server is less busy when people
aren't interact with the system in real
time so fractions for the rescue right
basically the solution revolved around
an implied list don't have to lock the
object you have a floating point rank so
you don't have to lock the siblings and
then you use an average rank or some
other function to figure out where it's
supposed to go and then we can defer the
rebalancing so there are there are a few
other pieces of it like what happens if
ten people want to insert something
between two and three well yeah we
covered that we added an epsilon based
off of time so now all of a sudden you
can handle the concurrency and
everyone's happy so if anyone has any
questions you can catch me afterward so
I'm going to talk on behalf of the
population a modeling working group and
actually I'm looking for people who
joined at a working group if this
interest some of you I saw some models
around here some of you may fit in this
category probably most of you won't but
those who will we want to we want you to
know about it and possibly join so what
is the population modeling working group
basically the background it is we
started under the head of the
interagency modeling of analysis group
I'm AG is a government group a group of
government people and they try to
promote modeling of simulation not
necessarily Python many many languages
many many types of models and simulators
a lot of them are medical in nature but
not only do i do ii some others there as
well they have all sorts of working
groups data sharing high performance
computing population modeling is one of
them so in the last meeting that was
there there was some interest in the
population modeling working group too
many a lot of people came over and we
kind of define that ed Hawk definition
of relation modelling is modelling a
collection of entities with different
level of the Avatar Genuity this is a
very broad definition and many things
fall into it even yesterday we saw
hearing under presentations they shown a
population of bikes it will fall into
this the bikes are entities and there
was a hell level of a church unity
because they go and start from different
locations but think about populations of
humans relation of cells populations of
animals all of those are population and
models and I'm going to show you some
examples I don't have enough to show
everything but I'm going to run for it
show you some slides that people left so
system epidermal epidemiology basically
clinical trials and models of those
again modeling diseases this is safe
from netherlands and you can see the
population pyramid hear that they
modeled and some disease there this is
called multiscale modeling this is
modeling of the liver this comes from
different places and you can get all
those slides online there on our website
in cintiq a modeling social behaviors of
mammals there are networks of those
those can be modeled can be very very
complex a population modeling like
preparedness for this
epidemiology again spread of disease
some YouTube attached to it if you
download the slides this is actually
population a population of cells what's
happening here they're modeling cancer
populations of cells it's another type
of population modeling are again
epidemiology spread of disease this is
basically human behavior what happens in
case of a disaster in this case nuclear
detonations one example a behavioral
modeling mental health models again
disease this one is a chronic disease
you can find this last year represented
it this is actually a Python library
also they do evolutionary computation
you can download it and see what it does
basically genetic algorithms also create
fallen under population modeling another
example is a discrete event simulation
many of you knows though no those
systems and skate event simulations so
they are used to figure out costs and
utilities wind in hospitals and even a
again sorry epidemiology another one of
those spread of disease and even our
mascot skeleton modeling differences
between different types of metal metal
anthropometric measures or some other
differences in the human body mask
skeleton examples so those are all
examples and we have some discussions on
our mailing list but I will let you go
through it and i would ask those who are
interested or know people who do
population modeling just go to our
website you can take a picture of this
QR code or go and go through that link
or sick us out under a sim tek and just
join the group if you're interested in
or just see what we're doing there and
then thank you
three slides here because I started
working on this at the beginning of the
when James started talking he insisted
that I give a talk so you can blame him
for all this so the title of this
lightning talk is let's do PI Texas and
I say let's do it because it's something
that we all do as a community to kind of
come together and every year it seems to
get more fun there's a youtube channel
that has some of the recent talks you
can see that we've had some very good
quality presentations in the last year
some of the videos from the older years
are kind of yet to be corralled but
eventually we hope to get them all up so
this is something about me in case you
have any questions there's my email
address um and twitter feed so how to
stay in touch how to find out about
announcements is probably the most you
know probably the best way is just to
follow on twitter the the main
organizers of pi Texas tend to post on
Twitter when there's new stuff going on
we also have a mailing list Texas at
python.org that is a place for everyone
across the state to participate and have
discussions sort of without being
limited to just your local user group
and of course if you join most of the
local user groups are on meetup so I
would highly recommend that you join
your local user group any time there's
an announcement generally the PI Texas
organizers will post it to the local
meetup groups as well and there is a
global Python announce mailing list so
just show you there here's the website
for pi Texas and its 25th through 27th
was just recently announced it will most
likely once again be in college station
which it has been for the past several
years because it's really a wonderful
venue at a low cost and and we don't
have any other anyone any venue
organized
stepping up in other places so that
seems like this will this is becoming a
regular thing the good thing is everyone
who attends knows where it is and we're
hoping to boost attendance I think we're
in the kind of in the 200 ish range
maybe we can get up to 300 this year and
here's the youtube channel you can see
there are there are talks you can of
course go to pi video org and find more
a more complete listing of talks about
pie Texas well pie video.com dot org I
think it's yeah this is the one this is
a great site if you don't know about it
hey I probably run past my five minutes
have an eye okay good come to PI Texas
sponsor attend help organize ask me if
you have any questions